and interest rates going up all the time
as we know could go even higher and that
impacts on mortgages as we've seen this
morning
sure I think the whole point okay here
that people are missing is that the
Savings mortgage is not it's not like
the mortgage market and that is why uh
you're seeing these allegations being
flung around I mean the mortgage Market
notwithstanding the fact that there are
fewer products on the market then though
there have been in previous months that
reflects the fact that money is more
expensive and uh accordingly uh it is
being uh you know there is a scarcity
around I mean over the last 15 years
we've had interest rates at near zero
and accordingly money has been very very
cheap so there have been lots of
mortgage offers out there you know
mortgages are like any other product
when the price goes up and down uh
demand and Supply will fluctuate
accordingly if you take the savings
issue though I mean I think what a lot
of people are missing in all of this is
that during the last 15 years you've had
interest rates at effectively zero and
that has really really crushed the
profitability of the banking sector I
mean the key thing to look at is the net
interest margin in the jargon that is
the difference between what the bank
tanks will charge borrowers and what
they'll pay out to depositors now when
you have ultra low interest rates or
near zero interest rates you get what's
known in the jargon that's Market
compression there is very very little
ability for the banks to make a turn on
what they're charging borrowers and
paying depositors now when interest
rates go up obviously there is more
flexibility to rebuild profits through
increasing that spread and accordingly
that's what the banks have been trying
to do I think there's a danger if you
over regulate this Market you're going
to end up in a situation as we've had
with the energy firms where you had an
energy price cap imposed and obviously
that policy turned out to be pretty
catastrophic when a lot of the
challenges ended up being caught out by
sudden moves in Energy prices and the
banks actually trade on this in the
savings Market if you cast your mind
back Kay to uh the build up to the
financial crisis you had these uh
Challenger savings businesses the likes
of ice saved there
paying very generous and competitive
savings rates and obviously they all
collapsed during the financial crisis
and accordingly the banks know that some
Savers are prefer to leave their money
with a trusted name like Barclays Lloyds
or HSBC on that West and accordingly the
bank's campaign uh charge a bit of a
premium for that I think the case for
the defense when they see The Regulators
will be for them to point to save fixed
rate savings products some of which are
pretty competitive it's these easy
access savings accounts where there are
there's less competition going on now
that I'm just looking at some of the um
profits from the banks for 2022
um Ian and we're not going to go around
with a begging Bill are we
no but I say okay you have to put this
into context with the with what's been
going on over the last 15 years where
the profitability of the banks has been
absolutely crushed because as I say
there's been uh ultra low interest rates
and there's been no scope for them to
move out their net interest margins what
you've actually seen since interest
rates have started to go up over the
last 18 months or so is that net
interest margins have gone back to kind
of where they were before the financial
crisis before we had this extraordinary
period of ultra low interest rates and
if you talk to analysts in the market
who have paid to to to to analyze the
the prospects of the banks I mean they
would say that they're not actually
making outright Bandits all that you're
seeing is a return to more normal
conditions and sort of normal conditions
we got before this extraordinary period
where we've had uh near zero interest
rates the last 15 years that's an
extraordinary period the trouble is that
a lot of people won't remember what
conditions were like in the market prior
to that you could actually say the same
with the mortgage Market too